[موسيقى]
كوابيس غزه لا يبدو انها تفارق حتى
العائدين من الحرب من جنود الاحتلال ليس
فريدا من نوعه ذلك الكابوس الذي ايقظ
مظليا اسرائيليا من نومه ودفعه دون وعي
لاطلاق النار على الجدار ما اصاب زملائه
بشظايا سبق لتقارير اسرائيليه الاعلان ان
500 جندي اسرائيلي اصيب بصدمات نفسيه منذ
بدايه عدوان الاحتلال على غزه قبل يومين
قالت صحيفه يد عود احرونوت ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اطلق برنامجا لمساعده الجنود
الذين يعانون من الاضطرابات النفسيه بسبب
الحرب في غزه اعتبرت الصحيفه اضافه
الاضرار النفسيه الى فاتوره خسائر الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الافراد قتلا واصابه واعاقه
ثمنا باهظا لا يطاق تفرضه الحرب في غزه
رعايه المتضررين نفسيا من جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم تقتصر على برامج التاهيل
فصدمت النفسيه والكوا تستدعي وفق تقارير
طبيه اسرائيليه حقنهم في المستشفيات بمواد
مخدره ليتمكنوا من
النوم الضغط النفسي لا يعاني منه جنود
الاحتلال العائدون من القتال فقط لكنه
ايضا وفق تقارير عسكريه احد المسببات
للخسائر الميدانيه الناجمه عما يعرف
بالنيران الصديقه والتي اخذت ارقامها في
التص مؤخرا بشكل لافت في الثان عشر من
ديسمبر الجاري اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل
20 من جنوده بنيران صديقه من اجمالي 111
قتيلا وفق احصائيات اليوم المذكور اي ان
خمس القتلى وفق ذلك البيان قتلهم زملائهم
قد يرى البعض في هذا الاعلان رغبه
اسرائيليه في الغض من مكاسب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لكن حديث النيران الصديقه لم
يتوقف بعدها بل تصاعد كانت قصه قتل الاسرى
الثلاثه ذروه ذلك المسلسل والتي وصفها
نتنياهو بماساه فوق الاحتمال ماساه لم
تتوقف بل تعددت الاعلانات الرسميه عن قتل
جنود اسرائيليين بنيران دبابات جيشهم قبل
عشر سنوات تباهت دراسه صادره عن اداره
الصحه العقليه بالجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الجنود الاسرائيليين هم الاقل تعرض
لاضطرابات ما بعد الصدمه حول
العالم لكن في الثالث من ديمبر الجاري
نشرت صحيفتها ارتس دراسه كشفت ان 34 في من
الاسرائيليين الذين سئلوا عن تعرضهم
لاحداث السابع من اكتوبر وصفوا اعراضا
تتفق مع اضطراب ما بعد
الصدمه